the daily caller tonight reporting that
the soros back democracy integrity
project
paid firms tied to fusion gps and
christopher steele
the foreign agent a whopping 3.8
million dollars in 2017 why to dig up
dirt on quote government entities
now despite all that we have uncovered
night after night
james comey while he's continuing to
remain defiant
insisting that he has nothing to hide
tried to remind him many times
jimbo you have the right to remain quiet
you may want to exercise that right as
you dig a deeper hole every day
like oh signing off on a fisa warrant
saying it's verified and telling trump
it's salacious but unverified months
later take a look
investigate what investigate that
investigations were conducted and what
would be the crime you'd be
investigating
so it's a terrible cycle to start he's
already started it with calling for the
locking up of his political opponents
including
people like me and so just be more of
that dangerous step and i would hope
although they continue to disappoint me
the republicans would finally stand up
and say we don't do that kind of thing
but me personally ask me questions go
ahead i'd like to answer them in the
daylight if i could
i'd like to see that too because now we
know a lot more than we did before here
with reaction senate judiciary committee
chairman senator lindsey
graham when the president was on this
program last week
senator president said very clearly he
will there will be a cascade of
information doug collins today
releasing yet another closed-door
testimony bill pre-step
in this particular case uh very
revealing
um then we're going to get the fisa
applications aren't we
the ones that the grassley graham
memo said the bulk of information came
from the
phony hillary bought and paid for
russian dossier
interesting then we're going to have
gang of aid information and
and we'll get 302 information
democrats aren't asking for that
transparency but we will get it and you
will continue you've made that promise
to us
yeah well let me tell you why because
millions of americans believe at the top
level the department of justice and the
fbi
they wanted clint dewine and trump to
lose they manipulated the law to let her
off
manipulated the facts in the law to go
after trump
and that's a big deal to a lot of people
republicans and some independents so i
promise you
former director comey will get to
testify the lie today i'll ask him about
the dossier
was it the chief reason you got a
warrant against carter page is it
verified to this day
if there's a counterintelligence
investigation open against the trump
campaign
why didn't you tell trump about it so he
could do something like you told
feinstein and at the end of the day how
could you write that clinton did nothing
wrong
even before you interviewed her and why
did you interview her with two of
two people in the room her aides and not
under oath most people don't get that
treatment all right so
the important thing is your committee
will take over where
the house intel committee left off so it
gives you a big leg up
but then i don't know at what point a
lot of this information will be released
i believe the president
is serious when he says that that
information is coming out you raise a
lot of other questions with comey i
would argue as
greg jarrett and others lawyers on this
program have argued
that there is a vulnerability for comey
there's a vulnerability for strzok and
page there is a vulnerability for mccabe
we know criminal uh referrals will be
coming this week from devin nunes
a number of them so so
criminality it's not my job to find out
if crimes were committed
it's my job as oversight of the
executive branch
did they bend the rules did they break
the rules to get an outcome
did they mislead the fisa court do we
need to change the rules about fisa
courts
are there any rules at all about
counterintelligence operations why
didn't you not tell trump
you told feinstein she had somebody on
her staff working with china why didn't
you go to trump and
tell him about suspicions about russia
was it a backdoor attempt to get in his
campaign
some prosecutor not a politician needs
to look at comey
mccabe and all of these characters to
find out if in fact
they broke the law and i'm hoping
attorney general bar will assign
somebody to this case with the same
resources
and commitment to look at them as
mueller had to look at trump
let's look real quickly at the border
crisis that is going on even hearing
from
barack obama's director of homeland
security yesterday
mark who we had on earlier in the
program uh real crisis
but donald trump his veto was not
overridden
that money will be repro reappropriated
nine
billion dollars um president tried to
work with democrats
the things they say they wanted they
wouldn't sit down with him right in a
way it's actually a bigger victory for
the president
more money than he ever dreamed of
probably enough to get a
real good chunk of this done and
complete
but i think these other countries see
what's happening and they're trying to
get to that border as quickly as
possible
knowing it won't be open as long as
maybe they thought
so i asked the head of the border patrol
do you need a wall and said absolutely
so the president stood firm
he has more money for a wall than he's
ever had because he's willing to declare
an emergency and there is one
but he also said if you don't change our
laws the wall won't work
right now if you step one foot into the
united states and claim asylum
you're entitled to a hearing we have no
place to put you in release you in the
country
if you come here with children you can
only be held 20 days we release you
because we have no place to put you
that's why we're being overrun by people
from the triangle countries because we
can't deport you back to those countries
if you don't change that you never fix
this and i hope democrats will help us
all right lindsey graham thank you we
appreciate you your commitment to go
forward get to the truth
and those that violated laws they need
to be held accountable we will do that
on this program as we have promised you